I want to follow up real quick on the
new California law which requires
children in public and private schools
to be vaccinated against ten different
illnesses and eliminates an exemption
based on the personal religious beliefs
of the parents so mandatory vaccination
in California for public and private
school attendance is not new that part
has been around for quite a while the
new part is you used to be able to get
an exemption for personal or religious
reasons which you are no longer allowed
to do numerous lawsuits being filed in
California over this in a few days ago a
federal judge refused to block the new
vaccination law saying and this is
judged anus a bra of San Diego saying
Society has a compelling interest in
fighting the spread of contagious
diseases through mandatory vaccination
of school-aged children the right to
practice your religion is not something
that outweighs the state's interest in
public health and safety this is a win
this law was prompted by a measles
outbreak two years ago which was traced
to some kids at Disneyland who had not
been vaccinated the law was implemented
last month this makes California one of
three states interestingly enough
California the liberal bastion
Mississippi and West Virginia are the
other two states that have these
mandatory school child vaccination laws
it makes California one of three states
to require school children to be
vaccinated I agree with this completely
the one thing I wonder when I hear the
story is what is the time frame of this
happening you know they can they can
move to keep vaccination on a on a high
level but they can't go move to get the
Zika virus uh you know vaccines out
there is no as I just want us wonder
about you know did this happen overnight
or is this a long term and at the same
time do they have the same power to
actually to do this for things are
relevant well i think that there's sort
of two separate issues here one is as
far as the power of enforcing this and
as we've mentioned you were only
required to provide proof of vaccination
in kindergarten and in seventh grade
which means that if you move
to this district in first grade you
would not be required to provide proof
of vaccination until 7th grade so you're
sort of getting at first of all the
logistics of the implementation of the
law which many people have talked about
but there's the other element I think
you're getting at which is this is a law
which seeks to sort of in it put in some
bureaucratic requirements to ensure
vaccination in some areas but meanwhile
we seem to be having a problem
effectively dealing with Zika is that
sort of the point you're talking about
exactly exactly yeah I mean legitimate
point i think it's it's sort of uh the
passing of this law does not directly
impact the research that is being done
with Zika so I think that that the sort
of we can walk and chew gum at the same
time type of thing this is one person
walking and then a different person
chewing gum so I do think that we can
work on both things uh in in parallel
and the the anti-vaccine movement
continues to exist among both of those
areas we see the anti-vaccine getting
involved in the Zika research and we see
the anti-vaccine volved in what's going
on with California vaccinations really
great piece by the way by former segment
producer and in turn Sam Miller on our
youtube channel called anti-vaxxers have
been around as long as vaccines take a
look at that to really understand the
history of the ban thai vaccine movement
this decision in federal court in
California uh absolutely a win we will
take a break and be back with thomas
frank next